وتزامنا مع هذا التصعيد العسكري اتهم
الرئيس الروسي بلادي من بوتين الغربه
بالكذب والنفاق بشان المساعي لحل النزاع
في دوم بس بطريقه سلميه وقال بوتين في
تهنئه للشعب الروسي لمناسبه السنه الجديده
قال ان العمل ماضي كان عامل قرارات الصعبه
وان الغرب اراد استغلال اوكرانيا لاضعاف
روسيا وتقسيمها حسب تعبيره
اهم الخطوات نحو تحقيق السياده الكامله
لروسيا لقد اصبحت هذه القرارات بمثابه
الحدود التي تاسس المستقبل للمشترك
واستقلالنا الحقيقي واليوم نحن نكافح من
اجل ذلك وحمايه شعبنا في اراضينا
التاريخيه وفي المناطق الجديده للاتحاد
الروسي لسنوات اكدت النخب الغربيه لنا
جميعا بشكل منافق على نياتها السلميه بما
في ذلك حل النزاع الصافي الغرب كذب بشان
السلام وكان يستعد للعدو واليوم هو كذلك
لم يعد محرجا يعترف بذلك بكل صراحه وهم
يستغلون اوكرانيا وشعبها باستخفاف لاضعاف
روسيا وتقسيمها لم نسمح ابدا ولن نسمح لاي
كان ان يحقق ذلك